In this problem, a big fancy house is built as shown and in parts 300 pounds per square foot
of vertical stress onto the ground beneath it.
Find the effective vertical stress in pounds per square foot at the given point in the
soil profile depicted.
So in the given figure, we can see our big fancy house imparting 300 PSF to the soil beneath
that we can see point A located in the clay and we can see all of the respective depths
relative to each other item.
We also have the groundwater level called out and the respective densities of the sand and
the clay.
So all we need to do is find the effective vertical stress at point A. So the first thing
we can do is note that the stress increases both with the depth and the density or unit
weight of whatever soil is above that depth.
So the first thing we can do is consider the stress just from the house and this number
is given to us directly as 300 PSF.
Keep in mind that those are the units we are looking for anyway.
Next we need to find the effective stress in just the dry sand.
So the section of sand to the depth of the groundwater level will be dry and that's going
to be 8 feet.
So the effective vertical stress for this layer is going to be the unit weight of the dry
sand times the depth of the dry sand.
And this is going to give us 880 pounds per square foot.
Next we can calculate the effective vertical stress in the saturated sand.
So if the total depth of the sand is 10 feet and the total dry depth is 8 feet then the
total saturated sand is going to be 2 feet.
So when calculating the saturated effective vertical stress it's important to remember that
any load carried by the saturated soil is carried by both the grains of soil and also
the poor pressure of the water.
So in this case we are actually going to be subtracting out the density of water from the
density of our saturated sand.
So first we are going to subtract 110 pounds per cubic foot by 62.4 pounds per cubic foot
which is the unit weight of water.
And you can look that up in the reference manual if you don't have that memorized.
And we are going to multiply it by the saturated depth of 2 feet.
And this is going to give us about 95.2 pounds per foot squared.
And finally we can solve for the effective vertical stress in the clay up to the given point
here.
So if the total depth of clay is 10 feet and we know the point is 5 feet above the
bottom of the clay layer then the depth of clay remaining will be 5 feet.
So just as we did before with the saturated sand we can subtract 62.4 from the unit weight
of the clay.
And then multiply by the depth to which we are going.
And this will give us 188 pounds per square foot.
So if we sum up each of the vertical stresses that we calculated from 1 to 4 we are going
to see that our total effect of vertical stress is about 1463 pounds per square foot which
we can see is our second answer.
A few things to point out for this problem would be to first remember to account for the
ground water at the depth that it exists and not to try to solve the problem for a deeper
point in the layer than the point being asked for.
Finally remember to account for the stress in the house that was given directly.
The height of the house does not matter but the height of the soil layers does because
we were only given density instead of effective stress.
But that is all it takes to solve this problem.